OUNTS TO
FRAUD, MONEY
LAUNDERING, THPUBLIC
FOUND, LYI TMANUTHE EA IA
SI
ANY INCUMBENT PORCTION.LS>> THP
MBS RUNNINVEERS WH PRIMARY
MOMENTTHAT HWI NOTORGE SANTOS RH
FAN FOR CTION.
BUT McHYD T  DID
I ASKED McCARTHY, WI TRY
TO DEAM?
HE SORT OF- ANY SORT O
THERE ARALRENGERS P AGAINS. HAS
THINGS G ON.
I THINK HE HAS OTHER THINGS CUST
RT AYIN A
PROCESS THAT PLAYS OUT HERE AND
MEMBERS HAVECTED, SERVE.
THAT ISSUE. BEEN DIFFERE
BUT HE DID S WOULD IF THE
HOUSE ETHICS COMMITTEE
NC AN INVESTIGIO SANTOS,ESD  SAA
CALL ON TO SANTOS BROKE TH W
McCARTHY SAID, QUOTE, YES.
SO THAT  SPEAKER'S BAR IN
TRYINGPU THERE IS S L CONSIDERA
THAT W SET UP
DEMOCRATS.DISTNTLL
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE AN ADVANTAGE
McCARTHY HASNL--
AFRD FOUR REPUBLICAN
VOTES IN ANY CE.
IF THAT BECAME AOC CLDO
LOSE THREE REPUBLICA NAADY VERY
SERVE OUANN FOR
RE-EIOIF HE RUNS FOR, THE
CONCERN IS TRM THEOLT
RY IMPNT YORK.YING HE WILLNOT S
>>.
COMMITTEE
TAKE TO CALG A LINE
FOR A RESIGNATION FOR
THANK YOU.
WOLF,  A IN E SPEAKER.
, INDEED. MANMENT DEFIANT RIGHT
SPKIO REPORTER WAY
OUT OFRTUS TO THN INDICTMENT.
WANTS TO COME AFTER ME ON AND I
P TO 20
CNARS IN PRISON IF CONVICTED.
Reporter: N YK RE
TRUMP PLAYBOOK
CRTER BEING INDICT
HEEA IS,IT'S A
>> RepBY
COURT CE, SANTAS PRESSED ABOUT E
FRAUDULENTLY RECEIVEN 4, UNEMPLI
WHILE HE WASNGT SED FIRM.
HIT OF MY DEFENSE.
THS INACCURATE
AN CLEAR MY NAME ON IS -- DURIN,
I DOUNRE THE
GOVERNMENT IS GETTING IT TINFORT
>>ter: THENDT
DETAIL
ALLEGATIONAT SANTO
CONTRIBUTIONS WHICH WERE TN
PERSONAL BILLS AND EVEN DESIGNER
EDERAL PROSECUTORS
STATEMENTS FILED WITH E HOUSE NC
OF REPRENT
BEING ELECTEKEN E ALLEGATIONS
IN THE INDICTMENT CHARGE RYI ON
DISHONESTY AND DECEPTION TO
AS
AND ENRICH HIMSELF.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY SAID IN STATE
GUILTY TO ALGED
RELEASED ON $500,000 BOND.
AFTES SUCCUL 2022 ECTION, HE WA,
WORKING FOR POWERHOUSE FINANCIA
LD TRADE
CEG . D I EMBELLISH MY
SORRY.
>> Reporter: T VETERANS ACCUSEFR
HIMSELF, SANTO IT'S AN OPEN WOU
TIME IEEI AM NOT IN THAT BADASX
D MORNING.
>>orD ABOUT
G  AGRANE  IAVANY TI
AND ME SAY , I'M THIRD QUARTE
IS
>> ReporteA
THE CONGRESSMAN'RELEASE, HE  TR
WASHINGTON.
NOW, TOMORROHE
PEIST.  GANINHE INTERIM, HE
AMATEV
IFORMERIOAD
MITCH McCONNELEN
SCOTT BROWN, FORU.S.
AMBASSADOR DINP ON AND THEICROH
THE DEFENSE DEPANTOKAY.
T IS
SCOTT.
IT COMES OUT F
SAYINGK THE RE-ELEION
CAMPAIGN HOUSETEE  GUILTCONCON
THEN I'LFOR HIHOW SIGNIFIC THAAT
ELY SIGNIFICANT
LEGAL PROCESS, WHICH HE IS,
ETHICS PITICALHE
WHICH HE
RETURN TTHRE ELECTIO HE IS UNDEK
HIM FOR
OB
CANDIDATES RUNNING UHIM.IF THE O
SOMEONE ELSE, THEY
CAN.
ANNOW TH
SO ALLE COD SSE ARE G CLOSED
ABOUJ, DON'T THINK PEOPLE THINK
RECENT BROADER CONVERSATIONS,
BUT THIS WASAST. WAST.ATYOU?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
WHAT THEY ARE RELYIN ARE HIS
PERSONAL FILING.
AS KE THFEC NGS, ETHICS FILINGS
THAT'S YOU.
YOU HAVE
SO THEY HAHALLEDPEIF THEY ARE NG
TE.  HO N E MOVE AND THEY AR
>> HE COULD FACE 2ES
CHARGES,OLID IS
CASE? AMBASSADOR IS  BCKPAPER CE
>> SUPER SOLID.
'S BASED ON DOCUMENTATION.
THEY DIDN'REALLYTESTIMONY FR WIR
WHILEG
INSUR. DIDN'T.NOT TEHEIN HIS DN
INSURAECKS AE
EITHEROT WIS AND SA
YOU GIVE ME $25,000, I PN
POLITICAL ADVERTISING, INSTE
HE FUNNELS IANLU>> McC S AVE E
FOR RESIGNATIOANYWAYS THIS.THAT
ISKYLECTION.
McCANLY HAS FOUR SEATS HE
CAAF>> THAT'S RIGHE INCR RISKY.
K A DEMOCRAT WOULD WIN.
DDISTRICT.
I THINK MANY WEREN'T
VERY SERIOUSLY, IF I'M BEING
HONEST.
B STAKEE
HIGHER.
IT'S NOT SPR YOU KNOW,
RELATIVELY EASY FO F
-ELECTION BECAUSHE NEEDS HIM.
YOU T LK ABOUT HOW HE
TEL.
THOSE PIECES OAT
CANG TO  THAT HE IS USING AS RT
FRANER, NEEDS TSE>> I
>> FOUR-VOTE MAR
TH-- AS TH
AMBASSADOR SAIBEFORE WCAME
, E ETHICS COMEES
SECRETIVE.
REHEY ARE INR PROCESS.
THAT COULD COME QUICKLY AN
BOOM,ELECTION.
>> YEAH.
AND IT WOULD BE VE
MPSUOULD IN ON IBL
I DON'T THINK BIDEN IS GNGOPARTV
BUT THISTH T
OF NOT DOING AS WELL IN THE
E SHOULD HAV
YOU KNOW, THE MARGIN
SHOULDN'T --
YOU D H ERRI I SAY
THIS SHOULD COO  "SURPRISE
POCY, AS SCOTTSOR  ON.IS PLAYIN
PLAYINS ROLE.
BUT THERE IS PLENTY OF BLAMEO
BIDEN WON BY TENMOCRATS DIDN'T .
THE